mr speaker the reports that the
prime minister and downing streets law
breaking have been damning
empty bottles
littering offices rooms so crowded
people were sitting on each other's laps
and security force to intervene
because the parties were so outrageous
at the center
was the prime minister orchestrating it
grabbing a glass for himself
in order to toast the party goers
eight months
we've heard every excuse under the sun
but now
now
we've all seen the damning photo
evidence
well people stayed at home to protect
the nhs
the prime minister
was engaging in drinking and debauchery
that makes a mockery of the
gut-wrenching sacrifices
that each and every person made
for the prime minister
for the prime minister now take the
opportunity and reside
mr speaker i can i can tell the the
right honourable gentleman that uh much
as i appreciate his advice he'll have a
further opportunity which i'm i'm sure
he will take to take his uh customary
length uh to to to debate that matter uh
in the course of the statement which
will follow directly after pmq's
i'm not happy
i'm like that was mr speaker but it's
all a joke to the prime minister
the prime minister
has lost the trust of the public
he has lost what little moral authority
he had left
the prime minister has apologized many
times not because he
feels any genuine remorse he still
refuses to even admit that there were
parties and that he presided over them
he apologized for one simple reason
he got caught
the reality is
no apology will ever be enough for the
families of people who lost loved ones
for the families who followed the rules
who stayed at home whilst their nearest
and dearest to them were dying and are
now forced to look at photographs of the
prime minister surrounded by drink
toasting to a party in the middle of a
lockdown
if the prime minister will not accept
that he must resign the natori benches
must act
this prime minister who has broken the
law
and shown a cavalier attitude to the
truth
cannot be allowed to remain in office
prime minister
time is up
resign
resign
resign before this house is forced to
remove him